[Music]
all right we're back baby joining me
this week is a radio host columnist
editor-in-chief of daily wire.com and
most importantly now two-time Rubin
report guest Ben zero welcome back good
to see ya
I thought you would be the right guy to
have for the first show in our new
studio I know what you're thinking but
sure yeah well because a lot has
happened since we last spoke
lastly I'd say roughly about a year ago
mm-hm and I was with you on election
night you had me over at the Daily well
star studios and we had a great time and
we had some beers you were reading a lot
of M&Ms oh yeah and now keep that sugar
intake up now the thing that I found
most interesting was that you did not
like Hillary right fair to say did I
yeah and I think she's awful do not like
Hillary Clinton clearly do not like
Donald Trump right so far I'm good no
you're right on the money so watching
you throughout that evening the
rollercoaster of emotion you were going
through going from when I sat down when
it's still look good for Hillary to then
it's starting to look like Trump then
realizing it was inevitable but before
they called it and everything else I
mean you went through every emotion it
was one too man bizarro world yeah it
was definitely weird because you know I
was as you know I was sort of rooting
for both of them to get left adrift in a
rowboat somewhere but unfortunately one
of them was going to be President of the
United States so there were there was a
bit there's a lot of up and down going
on meaning that I was overjoyed that
Hillary was not President of the United
States anything the kept Hillary out of
the White House I was very happy about
and then I looked at who was actually
entering the White House and well this I
have some some trepidation about not
sold on this whole Trump thing because I
hadn't been I didn't end up voting for
either of them yeah I left the blow at
the top of the ticket blank neither of
them fulfilled my basic requirements to
be President of the United States so now
you know I was wrong about where I
thought Trump would be I thought Trump
was gonna lose just like everybody else
was looking at the polls from Nate
Silver to Larry Sabato and and I was
clearly 100% wrong on that so now I just
hope that I'm wrong about him as a
person and a president yeah because if
I'm right then it's gonna be along for
years I have a feeling that no matter
what happens it's gonna be alone after
sure yeah whether he does good stuff and
people come along for the ride or
whether he does massive and they
nobody does good stuff then I can feel
good about right like I'm hoping that he
does some good stuff yeah yeah at this
point you have to write even if even if
you've got like any of his the positions
he's take over the the moral Center that
seems to my lawyers you you do root for
him as a president well as I root for
him to do good things I don't like the
phrase people use this with Obama also
root for him and I don't root for Trump
I don't for a bomb I didn't root for
Hillary it's not a team sport there I
like the White Sox and the Bears and the
Celtics I root for them I would like to
see them win but in politics it's not
just about winning it's about what you
do to win it's about the policies that
you implement that constitute winning
like how do you actually gauge winning
so for me when when Trump makes a bad
deal that's good for him politically
that's not something I'm in favor of
right I'm not rooting for him even
though it helps him politically I'm
rooting for him to do good things so I'm
rooting for me right I'm rooting for the
country
I'm rooting for him to do the things
that will help the country more than
makes I'm fine but it will help that'll
help the country but what I fear is that
I think people are rooting for him or
rooting against him and if that's your I
said this on my podcast today if your
moral Center is basically good for Trump
is good for the country or bad for Trump
is good for the country you need a
different moral Center right so that
seems to be the place that we're at
right now where Trump said I'm gonna win
I'm a winner and that that force of will
was almost enough in and of itself an
amazing thank him a winner
so is your version of winning which
would be you know having certain sort of
ethical code or whatever whether we
agree on all every little policy is
irrelevant right but can you win on that
any more now that we've seen how Trump
won do you honestly think that a
conservative can win playing the game
that's out there yeah I mean I do think
that I think that some of the things
that Trump did and I said this very
early on I mean very early before he
started kind of making an ass of himself
repeatedly I said that actually there
was a good shot that he would be a
better nominee in terms of winning than
Marco Rubio because I thought that he
spoke a moral language about politics a
lot of the other candidates didn't mean
go look back at my speech that I gave at
University of Missouri in like October
2015 and I said the Trump might be
stronger especially among blue-collar
whites in states like Wisconsin
Pennsylvania and Michigan so I got it
right then I got it wrong year later
right but it but the but the idea there
is that Trump speaks in terms of
morality they're good guys and bad guys
right whether whether you agree with his
moralities another thing but for politic
for him all politics breaks down as good
guys versus bad guys unfortunately very
often it's just I'm the good guy
everybody who opposes me is the bad guy
but that's a way that people think about
politics and I think that if you had the
actual proper moral you know content to
that sort of narrative then yeah you
could still win based on that it's so
funny everybody's sort of because
everybody is a binary thinker everybody
broke it down into Trump is the only one
who can campaign aggressively he's the
only one who can speak this moral
language no I wasn't against Trump
campaigning aggressively or speaking
this moral language I just thought that
he was applying it incorrectly I mean if
you watch me in debate I'm constantly
applying moral language I'm constantly
aggressive but I disagreed with Trump
you can you can do both at the same time
yeah so are we at a point then of post
truth because if you look at what he
says now again most of the criticism I
get right now is that I'm being too kind
to him I I've been saying for weeks now
we have to see what happens I can't get
outraged about appointments yet I have
to wait to see you know right you can
get a sense of what's going on oh that's
right I'm not let's see what happens but
I think that's right I'm not not
outraged about the appointments you know
what he does and what he says I can be
outraged by and I think that there's an
incentive structure that has to exist or
if he does something bad now now I
criticize him the argument was made
during the election cycle for people on
the right well if he says something bad
che IL re might get elected right right
and my view was that's not my job my job
is to as somebody who actually believes
in something that's truthful my job is
to say what I think is true whether he's
saying it or not but now especially
post-election Hillary's no longer in the
picture so the question now is if he
does something that's false are you
going to call that out even if you're
politically on his side overall and
that's that's the real question for me
so my job I still is the same as it ever
was when he does something good I praise
and when he does something bad I don't
yeah
which really is not what many people
people though on that now people people
and what fine do they not want because I
suspect they wanted it's what I'm trying
to do I know it's remedial it hasn't it
hasn't hurt me you know with other with
most people most people are refreshed
when they hear somebody like you or like
me say okay here's the truth you know
and I'm putting my own political
interests aside in the interest of the
person who's at risk here then here's
here's what's true and here's what's not
but there's a large contingent that's
going to resist that in a major way
because again it has become such team
sport it has become
if you say something bad about Trump
then you're a and you're in you're
undermining him and it's like well again
that's bill o'reilly said that about
George will George will criticize the
carrier deal and a Riley comes out and
he says George Boole is just undermining
Trump it's a wait a second he's not my
dictator right I'm not he's my surveyor
it's not right it's not the opposite I'm
not his servant he's my servant he's a
public servant now I know that he's been
in private business his whole life and
he's running for the job of public
servant now it's his job to serve the
interests of the American people
it's not my job to serve as his
political interest yeah and so you know
it's it's been very weird to watch
people kind of invert that and I thought
that that was unique to the left so I've
been disabused that pretty radically yes
so that that's really interesting and
maybe maybe my feelings about what's
happening with the left just kicked in a
little bit more a little earlier than
yours have kicked in about the right man
it's true because you are seeing this
and it's pretty obvious I mean to me the
issue will be that once these Trump
people who have been all for you know
against political correctness and every
speech and all of this stuff and same
way you feel about which I'm for all of
more so I but once on January 20th once
those are the guys that are in power
will they be as for fighting the power
no no no I mean Kellyanne Conway today
right i mean Kellyanne Conway was out
there criticizing I think it was Bret
Stevens from The Wall Street Journal
Bret Stevens from The Wall Street
Journal was making fun of Carly Fiorina
because she went to Trump Tower and he
says like five minutes ago you were
saying is the worst person who ever was
and he's making funnier face and now
here you are Trump Tower and Kelly Ann
Connolly tweets back at at Bret Stevens
and she says something like that's
really sexist what do you think and then
she tags Rupert Murdoch right who owns
the Wall Street Journal right and so is
this the way that this is going to go
now that we're going to go to the bosses
of the people who we don't like what
they're saying right that's someone
literally in the incoming administration
tagging someone I mean Sean Hannity did
the same thing today somebody red-state
criticized him didn't like something
that he did so he immediately tagged the
heads of Salem Communications at Owens
red state I mean like is this something
that we want to engage and this is this
is not like I disagree with people all
the time I generally don't call for them
to be fired I mean that's that's it
sometimes like there was a point where I
suggested that there there should be if
some if they've left us we're going to
apply certain tactics then you have to
apply the same tactics to people on the
left in order to create a sort of
mutually assured destruction but that's
not what's going on now now what's going
on is you criticize
certain people and those people just say
you ought to be fired just for the
criticism in fact I've never blocked
anyone on Twitter
I don't mute anybody on Twitter so all
of the all the evil terrible tweets that
I receive I've never called for anybody
be banned from Twitter even though you
know I was according to the ADL the
number one recipient of anti-semitism or
what line is that to that so I mean it
did but I've never but that's not my
thing but watching people on my own side
do it now it's like well you should shut
up because because Trump no no sorry
it's not the way it works yeah can you
win that battle I mean I yeah I think I
read through exactly I mean as you know
you wouldn't be in this business I
wouldn't be in this business if I didn't
think the battle were winnable I think
that in the afterglow of a an election
it's very difficult for people to get
past the team sport of it and the the
warm feeling and the excitement so I
immediately I mean as you mentioned that
night I kept going from excitement to
trepidations excitement to trepidation
to oh my god I can't believe this was
the election and but a lot of people
just went straight to we hate Hillary
Clinton so much everything is now
hunky-dory no problems anymore
Trump's here I alone can solve and I
think that'll last up until the point
where the pedal hits the metal and then
we'll see what kind of policies he
actually implements and whether people
are willing to stand up my bet is that a
lot fewer people will be willing to
stand up and and not back in when he
does bad things then then you would have
thought a year ago yeah I guess we shall
see what what's next what okay so he
becomes president he starts doing
whatever he's doing the left
automatically and this has been my fear
all along is if you demonize someone to
the point where even if they do good you
have to keep demonizing them because if
he's a racist bigoted even if they
really take over there and if a racist
bigot does good things for the economy
well you can't be nice to him right
because he's he's the scum of the earth
what happens after this because it seems
to me that I think we're going to start
seeing more of a trend of violence and
you know the state coming down on more
violence like it just seems like this is
where this has all been led up to and
he's the guy to lead the fight against
that well I mean the level of radicalism
that's emerged on both sides in terms of
the the wild intolerance for people with
different political opinions is pretty
extreme as you're saying uh you know I
think that if Democrats were smart
they'd actually see this as kind of an
opportunity do that my guess is the
Trump's gonna governor's as more
a centrist Democrat than he is a
hardcore right-wing Republican he's
really not other infrastructure packages
and he's talking about tariffs and he's
talking about a lot of Bernie Sanders
kind of policies he's a populist right I
do that's right and so you could win so
what you could see Democrats doing is
doing exactly what they did to Herbert
Hoover if let's say things go bad right
let's if things go well he'll be
reelected because the president who's
president when things are going well
generally is reelected but let's say
things let's say for the sake of
argument things don't go well let's say
that just as as every eight to ten years
for the last several decades in this
country there's some sort of recession
and Democrats blame Trump for it what
they could do is they could campaign on
tripl tripling down on the populism
right I mean they actually have that
opening now whereas they didn't before
and they could actually do FDR to Hoover
they could say Hoover kind of
implemented a lot of soft FDR policies
and then FDR came in and tripled down on
everything and gets elected four
straight times you can see Democrats
doing this things shift really quickly
in the country and Hillary did win by
about 3 million popular votes so this
isn't quite the the massive majority the
Republicans are banking on but I do
think that if they're if their rhetoric
is this extreme you know during the
campaign the question is going to be
whether they ratchet it up or whether
they sort of Ratchet it down and wait to
see what happens I'm seeing some of both
I'm seeing some bug that's a yes I hope
you're right like Harry Reid for example
came out he says so far Trump's not not
that bad hmm
which is something that should make
conservatives a little concern but but
Harry Reid says that you could see
Democrats move in that direction he's
not that bad and then things collapse I
told you he was that bad right but the
other because they want to get some
liberal policy out him some lefty policy
at him but on the other hand what's
going on in university campuses and the
and the sort of extreme response that I
think is going to get a lot worse I
think the Democrats in government will
likely treat him with more moderation
after the election they did before the
election because that sort of in the
pattern but the typical public is going
to treat this is like we're now in an
end of times politicking right so I
guess that so that's an interesting
distinction that the the sort of
leadership whether it's the media or the
political leadership may be willing to
work with them in a certain way but
they've ginned up something yes in the
populous that they maybe can't control
exactly an actual you're seeing that
battle play out in the Democratic Party
right now you've got the people who want
to double down on all the kind of
identity politics rhetoric like keith
Ellison right who's going to double down
on that and he's going to keep saying
racist
suspected homophobe let's get a
coalition together the Obama coalition
will run some who's not a little white
lady next time will run Cory Booker
Kamala Harris and then we'll just sweep
back to victory using this new coalition
that's demographically growing and then
you've got people like Joe Biden and
some of the old guard Democrats who are
saying well hold on just a second like
we can actually why are we abandoning
all of these these blue collar white
voters who were voting for us until very
recently right a lot of these counties
went for Obama the first time and why
don't we why don't we try to draw them
in by may be working with Trump and then
if he and then and then hitting him when
we think that he's over overly selling
something or hitting him when things go
bad yeah and that that conflict will
really play out at the DNC level and
that's that's a fascinating one yeah I
mean I'm I would bet everything that
they're gonna go the Bernie Ellison
rumored to dump everybody else you think
there's any room for those people at you
know for a Jim Webb Biden and those
happen to be two older white even anyone
in that general line of thinking blue
dog um Brett is that no Jim Webb right I
think Jim Webb's toast Biden still tries
to straddle that gap a little bit and he
gets away with it is part of the Obama
administration yeah but it's yeah I
think they're gonna be gradually dragged
to left cuz again our entire life left
has been gradually dragged further and
further from I'm waiting to see the
moderate since question even better day
I think for a long time that the right
got dragged further and further to the
right but this election clearly they
were no they weren't they were dragged
left actually pretty hard they work I
mean Trump doesn't it's obvious he
doesn't care about gay marriage I don't
think you know social I don't think he
cares about abortion I don't know cares
about weed I think even some of the tax
stuff I think is gonna be a little more
you Manning of a centrist Democrat I
think govern a lot more like Bill
Clinton then II then you would govern
like Ron already that's the danger
though if you demonize somebody to that
end point and then even if they are with
you on so many of the things that you've
been screaming about for so long
you're you've painted yourself into the
corner yeah I think I think that's right
and I think the Democrats have painted
themselves in a little bit of a corner
except that they're just banking on the
growth of the Obama coalition I keep
looking at the demographic numbers
yeah and they keep thinking okay in 2020
forty percent of all voters will be of
the millennial generation those people
broke heavily for Hillary so what's to
stop us now and demographics are not
quite destiny I mean demographics are
like that what is the same way what a
sad way that would be to live as a
society
that we would only be following the
demographic trend but that's what we are
right now I mean it's we've moved in
such a tribal direction too I mean it's
easy to look at this election cycle and
look at did he win on policy I don't
think that the Trump won on policy so
much as rejection of tribalism in favor
of another sort of tribalism like if you
look at how blue collar white voters
voted in this election cycle by
percentage white were a white
working-class people voted more for
Trump than Hispanics voted for Hillary
Clinton we're constantly talking about
the the idea that Hispanics are voting
bloc okay well then so right blue-collar
people presumably and they voted
precisely the reverse they were 71
percent for Trump that's it the again I
don't have a problem with people of any
group voting however they want to vote
but if if it starts to look like a
voting bloc like our group interest
solidarity I don't think that's that's
totally what's happening on the bunch of
white people getting together and going
we got a vote against those black and
Hispanic people right um just like I
don't think that it's all Hispanic
people getting either we need to vote
against the white yeah but but there is
that that growing sense that you're
going to vote inside your own block and
in that is not a good thing do you think
that's actually real though because
every time I watch John King with magic
wall that I'm pretty sure he's having an
affair with during the commercial break
but every time I watch him do that is it
well the white working-class people here
the black people here in the Latino
people here in this whole thing and it's
like not only does that actually sort of
sound racist and I don't know does it
like you're actually just pinning
everyone by these these traits but it
also it doesn't sound logical
I don't think and maybe I'm really wrong
here but I don't think most people vote
on the color of their skin or no I don't
think so either but I think that they
vote like their neighbors vote and so
and so if they see that their neighbors
are voting a certain way and there's a
certain revenge politics to everything
and this is not unique to one group it's
like the the system has screwed us yeah
the system has screwed us is one of the
ways that politics dies there that
notion the system has screwed us and I
don't just mean like the government if
you can show that the government is
specifically disadvantaging your group
that's one thing when you just say the
system broadly is screwing us and it's
us as white blue-collar workers or it's
us as black people or it's us as
Hispanics that's a really damaging thing
and and that I think is rising pretty
dramatically yeah and and that's
partially because the only way the
politics operates and I've spoken about
this at
recently uh but the only way the
politics actually operate society
operates is is through building the
social fabric the idea that we are
individuals we're going to treat each
other's individuals we're not going to
treat each other as members of groups
left to spend so long breaking people
down into identity group politics that
the right responded with the tone form
of okay we'll screw you were you know
you've already boxed us in so okay now
that we're in the box were in the box
like that's what it is right it's almost
like they're they hated it for so long
but now they're embracing it usually
right I've tried so hard to have the
left back away from some of this stuff
yeah exactly exactly I'd like to see the
right back away from some of this stuff
I think that's what a lot of the all
right controversy was about yeah because
they're really open about the tribalism
but I mean there's no question that some
of what Trump was doing was it was a
quasi tribal appeal right I mean when
when he was talking about tariffs for
example the tariffs that he's talking
about you know he's saying that he
obviously they're equally applicable to
people living in the United States but
really who he's talking to and everybody
knew this and it was repeated ad nauseam
in the media was he's talking to white
blue-collar voters from Ohio
Pennsylvania Michigan in Wisconsin and
when you say to people that you can
indirectly tax other people for your
benefit right right which is what a
tariff is but it's okay for the white
people but we also don't like the
welfare system for the black people then
you start getting into some really you
know kind of interesting political
territory and the idea that it was a
totally race free campaign by Trump is
not true I mean it just it wasn't like
the the fact is that the Donald Trump
was making not overt references to race
but he was making subtle appeals on the
basis of any one thing it was a race
free campaign are there people I think
they're people yeah Kellyanne Cano is a
go-to example right she says she said
there was the big debate between her and
Jen Palmieri from the Clinton campaign
Jen Palmieri said that you guys were
pandering to the alright and Kellyanne
Conway said you're accusing me of being
part of a campaign that would pander to
the alright and Jen Palmieri said yeah
and but Kelly ended the who me me what a
yeah you a little bit okay yeah and yet
at the same time the Democrats were
pandering to everybody right keep saying
we don't exactly don't talk about race
but every other line was right exactly
and so it's and so you have both sides
playing the same game now and none of
them are playing inside the mentality
that were I exist which you know you put
outside the conservative box for a
second I am well essentially a radical
individualist in the sense that I think
that people ought to be treated as
individuals they shouldn't be treated as
part of
and so treating voters as part of a
group or a classical liberal yeah that's
right that's right
and do that sure unlike the
european-style classical limo yeah I
mean except that yeah I mean with which
I really like the conservative thing
enough that even to say that oh but I
know I mean I'm more I'm more kind of a
conservative libertarian mashup than
anything else I think the government
sucks at everything right I mean like
we've talked about same-sex marriage
before yeah I personally against
same-sex marriage but I don't think the
government has any business in it and
personally again smoking marijuana I
don't think the government has pretty
much any business in it if you're not
creating externalities I don't think
that the government has any business
messing with you and that's why I
consider cross from you and you can say
that and it doesn't bother me because
right not trying at this point you're
not trying to stop either one of those
things right exactly and why so you can
believe what you want to believe this is
one lecture I know I'm supposed to be
offended probably not something this is
right but this is this is the thing it
is so funny I was talking to somebody
one time and they were saying you know
as a religious person you think
homosexual behavior is in as a raisin
Orthodox Jew right it's in the Bible I
think it's a sin
yeah here's the beautiful thing about
America you don't have to give a crap
yeah really good you know you can think
I'm an idiot that's fine right welcome
to America and you don't use seriously
can completely disregard everything I'm
saying because I'm not trying to use a
gun reinforce my opinion against you
you're not trying to gun and actually
you're not even trying to use the Bible
because right exactly not trying to
govern by the Bible that's that what
you're saying that's right you're saying
you have your private belief right
exactly when did we lose this ability to
have the privately because did you see
this about a week ago
BuzzFeed did a piece on the two people
from that HG TV show yeah I'm liking on
the show I watch it sometimes the games
got the gay Joanna and whatever said I
wanna be yeah but they you know they do
this house flipping show might be great
flip or flop flop flip or whatever it's
called uh but the point is I was I was
out is I watch the show many times they
strike these two completely benign
whatever fine people like yet their jobs
seem like these people and the whole
piece in BuzzFeed was that they go to a
church that's against gay marriage and I
thought this is the worst kind of smear
job nonsense exactly and but when did
that become okay that so what they they
go to a church where we don't know what
their beliefs are on it and I wouldn't
care actually right exactly and even if
they believe that as long as they're not
manifesting that and discrimination
against gay people who gives a crap
right I mean this is this is what
I mean first of all the idea that HGTV
is short on pandering together patently
insane okay my wife watches each do you
think we learned all about I mean look
have you decorated but what's what's but
it is amazing that that sort of thought
policing I mean that's existed for a
couple of decades probably since the
sixties for the left but the fact that
it's starting to exist a little bit on
the right is what frightens me is is the
the thought policing uh that I see
because it policies become a loyalty
test but it's also it's so selective in
what everyone does because I would
guarantee you mentioned keith Ellison a
moment ago I'm gonna guess that the
mosque that he goes to is probably the
Imam is probably not for Naaman area but
BuzzFeed we I'm just guessing on that
but I'm pretty sure that that's majority
mosques and I probably 99.9% of us in
America are not okay that's fine they
can have their personal religious belief
but BuzzFeed would never do a piece on
that if anything they'll whitewash
everything he's ever said about
Farrakhan and everything right exactly
so that just shows you how the media has
again they said they were fine with with
Obama's excuse that he went to a church
for twenty years where Jeremiah Wright
was preaching the most insane crap
imaginable from the pulpit and they went
okay well you know that's his church
nobody says he has to believe that so
wait wait a second why is that that's
okay for Obama but it's not good for
gains Obama's like he's gonna actually
run for president like if at any point
the guy's views are going to be relevant
you think it's more that then I don't
know are you going to knock out a
barrier and create an open kitchen
concept that HIV right right it's it
yeah
it is it is it is pretty it's pretty
wild how far things have gone I'm hoping
that I think that a lot of people who
are hoping that Trump is going to be a
blowback against that that you know
there will be less thought policing
under Trump but that also has to apply
to Trump right right there has to apply
to Trump himself and happy to find it
chief when Kellyanne Conway's tagging
people bosses on Twitter that they don't
like that doesn't that's not a good time
I mean Donald Trump was making those
noises all throughout the campaign
raising he wants to rewrite libel law
which for people in our business is like
I mean all we do sit all day is sit and
give opinions and the idea that we're
going to be sued for giving those
opinions is is pretty frightening thing
in the United States yeah it isn't so
much of that though and I I think you've
already said it but that it's just a
reaction to the lunacy yes in terms of
reaction the reaction him is reactionary
there's no question but reactionary
politics is bad politics right you
should at the reaction to the left is
breaking people down by race and by
identity politics is not well screw them
let's do identity politics too if they
can do what we can do it you know that's
not that well that's not the way that
you got to play the game I mean it's and
if you think that's the only way we can
win then we're bound for a
european-style politics it's the end of
American politics like what America used
to be about was the idea that as
individuals we disagreed about a lot of
things but we agreed that we're going to
be treated as individuals or at least
that was that that was supposed to be
the promise that we were attempting to
fulfill in Europe it all breaks down
according to demographic lines and you
just have a battle between the big
government right the big government left
and are you gonna let immigrants this
time you're not going to get lettin
immigrants this time that's that's yeah
and I think that we're in danger of
moving that way just we're gonna we're
going to shred and fried our way right
into something really ugly yeah in a
weird way though this presents a
tremendous amount of opportunity right I
was telling you right before we started
I was with you a couple weeks ago Dennis
Prager had a had a fundraiser mm-hmm and
I thought he gave a really great speech
about basically saying the world is in a
really nuts place right now maybe we
have to find allies in other places and
that's what I think I've tried to do so
there is for all the chaos of it yeah
there's some real opportunity I hope so
and I hope that it's a I think it's a
good opportunity for and when I do my
podcast I actually keep a physical shoe
on the side and I and I hold it up and I
say put this on the other foot whenever
Trump does something I just put this on
the other with Obama into this how would
you feel and it's a good opportunity for
people on the left to do the same thing
I think that if we all sort of take the
shoe and put it on the other foot like
now you're very upset with what Trump's
doing but how are you with it when when
Obama was doing it if you think the bad
one Trump's doing it maybe it was bad
when Obama was doing it and for the
right if you were really pissed off
about it when Obama was doing it now
Trump's doing it maybe you should be
pissed off on Trump's doing it and if
everybody applied that sort of
intellectual honesty I think to whatever
our politicians do
we'd be significantly better off because
the fact is that it's the team sport of
it that ruins it it's the team sport of
it that where you end up with I'm gonna
root for for my guy just no matter what
he does no matter what rules he breaks
and this is why I've said it's not team
sport politics is not team sport like as
a White Sox fan there's a catcher who
caught for us named AJ Pierzynski and AJ
Pierzynski was a player that everybody
hated and still hates in the major thing
to the Braves now yeah and they despise
him because he was this guy who'd like
cut any corner to win he's not on your
team you hate him and then he's on your
team and you'll love it yeah well
anything in order to win the problem is
that when you apply that to politic
and it's if he's on my team and he'll do
anything to win that's awesome yeah well
except for it isn't because now you have
to you have to be standing up for people
doing bad things yeah and that's the
strange thing I mean look if you for all
these people that are upset that oh that
Trump might be a war monger or might be
against the press now he might be but at
this but a he didn't run certainly on a
pro war policy but B Obama has been
doing drone strikes in Afghanistan
bright rikes in Pakistan ask Edward
Snowden how he's been for press freedom
and all that kind of stuff so regardless
of what how you feel terrible for press
for so it's like wait nobody why were
you guys saying anything you'd have a
little more right you'd have a little
more weight to your words now exactly I
said this on brian Stelter show on CNN
is they were going nuts over this is
when when Trump was tweeting against
Hamilton and I said like let's let's be
fair to both sides if Obama had done
this to a NASCAR event like some NASCAR
event in 2011 booed Michelle and he'd
gone on and said these NASCAR people
should shut up and apologize basically
you know it would have been applauded
but he would've been applauded by the
left and now Trump doesn't on Hamilton
and it's just the end of the world oh my
God he's gonna shut down our beloved
Hamilton and he's by the way his right
it's an overrated musical but they but
it but on the other side I haven't seen
it on the other side you know you had
people on the right and they're like
yeah look at Trump really punching
really really taking it to him it's like
right but when Obama did exactly the
same sort of stuff when he was calling
out Fox News by name and saying that it
was that they were destroying the
political process we were saying wait
the President of the United States
should be going on attacking specific
news outlets for how they report that's
really gross some when I had somebody
tweet me saying why didn't you ever say
this stuff about Obama and I linked
directly to a video from 2013 where I
said exactly this about Obama
yeah and it's in again you could
probably spend your whole life trying to
correct the things that people tweet but
that's what happens is that people get
into this the they get into this this
mode where yeah when Obama did it it was
the Democrats didn't care
and it's like yeah but that that
argument also applies to you you did
care when Obama did it and now you're
pretending not to so the hypocrisy
argument cuts both ways it's
double-edged sword you can't claim the
Democrats are hypocrites about Trump at
the same time that you're being a
hypocrite about Obama
you
[Music]